for the last two months Iranians have
protested against the government
following the death of a 22 year old
woman Joshua peguero Joins us live after
speaking to locals
All Over Las Vegas the game was shown
including in the facade behind me at
Resorts World but Iranians that I spoke
with say that conflicted about the match
while they want to support Iran they can
support the Iranian regime and its
brutal Crackdown on protesters
I mean they're killing kids they're
killing little boys little girls they're
killing teenagers Samira knights's
parents moved to Las Vegas as kids to
escape persecution from the Iranian
regime her dad who is Jewish can't
return to the country this is bad and
people in Irani they are hostage
basically Knight says watching the
recent unrest makes her upset she and
other members of the chamber have
organized local vigils and met with
congresswoman Susie Lee to discuss the
situation they'd like more U.S
involvement these people they have
nothing else to live for but Freedom
it's not like Ukraine and Russia who are
fighting each other in a war this is
people who have no guns who have nothing
who have rocks and sticks severish
akrami immigrated to the United States
in 2008 to study at UNLV he graduated
with the green computer science he is
following the protests closely there is
a great Unity among the people
previously it was only the big cities
now it's in every little town you see
protest you see the videos coming out
the recent protests began in September
after a woman who was arrested for not
wearing a headscarf died in police
custody akrami says these protests may
be hard to end with the number of people
who have died recently I don't see this
being suppressed easily anymore
an Iranian General recently said that at
least 300 people have been killed while
the group human rights activist puts the
death toll much higher they say at least
451 protesters have died reporting live
Joshua progero eight news now